move your queen to the square and guard  your Central Pawn and he doesn't oh no  okay now it's been turned around now  black is going to win what look at that  so can I take this Pawn first of all  that is one question maybe you can  maybe this is just the key for Magnus  this Pawn getting it's not just the pawn  it's getting the queen centralized and  he does take it now this is a monster  threat now the white king is not safe  and Black's King  surviving just about  I mean it's just the clock Vincent  didn't have enough time there to work  things out but just a bit greedy I guess  with this last Pawn capture  and uh what to do now for example this  check can simply be met by the king  running to the side the Black Brook does  a great defensive job  the evaluation bar only says plus 1.3 so  there must be a way for Vincent to keep  alive  keep the fight going  okay he moves this Rook across very  natural this Knight is pinned now in